First, we want to add 4 to both sides to get this polynomial by itself. Now,
we're in a position to complete the square. We know our b is positive 4. So, b
divided by 2 equals 2. And b over 2 squared is equal to 4. This is the amount
we need to add to both sides of our equation in order to complete the square.
So, we'll have positive 8 on the right and then we'll have x plus 2 for our
perfect square on the left. Keep in mind, this positive 2, comes from our b
over 2 term. This is positive 2, so this is positive 2. Another way to find
this number, is the take the square root of this term and use the sign for the
b term. The square root of 4 is 2 and we use the positive sign, since this sign
is also positive. Next, we take the square root of both sides of our equation,
to get x plus 2 equals positive or negative, 2 root 2. Finally we subtract 2
from both sides, to get our two answers for x.